foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
SportsCenter anchor golf host all-around
good guy and how do you think we did a
little research for a change we we
wanted to welcome you to welcome you
back thanks for joining us Scott it's my
pleasure Barbara hit him with a Curtis
blow oh yeah
Curtis blow yeah uh you're you're all in
on your Orioles there judging from your
t-shirt is that what we have
Dan having done this uh as we both have
for a while people send strange things
in the mail am I right yes they do look
at my man cave that's all it is it's
stuff that I got exactly collected
exactly okay so when the Orioles were
horrendous for the past few years
anytime they would win I would just
scream in the very Baltimore East uh
dialect oh Strays and daddy bears on and
that's how we would celebrate one of the
50 some odd wins 52. someone sent me
this I think this is one of one uh it's
ostros and Addie bosheim well now
they're quite good and so those of us
that sort of endured uh you know I'm not
peacocking around here and acting like
they're you know going to the playoffs
but they've got a really talented really
good team and I'm just I'm happy for
them I'm not happy for any of the guys
that have been around for a while
Brandon Hyde and all the all the uh long
time
those who are now good well I think it's
three playoff appearances in the last
quarter quarter Century not a lot no not
a whole lot
a lot
uh what's your first memory as an oriole
fan
Memorial Stadium with my dad uh um like
three Buck night uh they used to be able
to get an upper reserved seat in
Memorial Stadium for three bucks and so
there'd be 20 000 people and 10 000
would be in this uh in the in the upper
reserves and then around the third or
fourth inning you'd work your way down
uh um I don't want to derail this but
I'll make it as quick as I can there
used to be a public address announcer
there by the name of Rex Barney and if
you're if a fan made a catch of a foul
ball and they made a good catch Rex
would say give that fan a contract
Brooks Robinson hits the foul ball my
dad jumps up makes a good grab catches a
Brook's foul ball I'm like 10. come home
from school the next day naturally we're
gonna play catch with the ball
throw it my my buddy misses it it rolls
down the street into his sewer it's gone
I tell this story at a charity event in
Baltimore 20 years ago
in the crowd is someone who does some
work with with Brooks
and a week later a box shows up at my
house and there's a note in the box that
says hope this makes up for the one in
the sewer Brooks Robinson so I'm not a
I'm not an autographed guy Dan but I I
have been my man cave I have one
autograph it's a baseball signed by
Brooks Robinson to make up for the one
my dad caught that I threw in the sewer
it's like Sandlot
you're kind of yeah your own version of
uh of Sandlin we're talking to uh Scott
Van Pelt are you retiring before I
retire
no no no I see I I'm not retiring I'm
just as far as like the whole Sports
Center thing goes all I when I went out
with Trina all I was saying was you know
sometimes you got to leave the party a
half an hour early rather than a half an
hour late you know what I mean you you
don't you don't want to be I don't want
to be dragging him dragging me out there
just going oh God the old guy let's
let's give him the O's throws to
Natty boes line and just bring him on
out there uh no no I'm not I'm not I'm
not up and I have no no interest in
abandoning the post necessarily I just
you know you just always got to look at
you gotta look at what's out there
figure out what you can what you can do
to stay uh relevant I got bored with
SportsCenter and I bet you did and I I
just I I sat in the chair one night and
I'm throwing to Sal palantonio and I'm
thinking what am I doing
because if I was just going through the
motions and I'm going yeah God I can't I
can't do that's I should not be sitting
in this chair somebody else younger
should be sitting there and I don't know
if you've ever had those feelings in a
show where you're going God do I want to
you know it's a young man's game
I agree with that and there are very few
people that would identify and
understand because I'm sure people might
roll their eyes and go how hard can it
be it there's a certain amount of mental
energy and then there's a certain amount
of physical energy and but by that I
mean that it's midnight or one in the
morning and you just need to be present
and awake and have energy and be
entertaining
um and no I there are there are nights
driving home in the Clara Barton Parkway
in in DC where you're dodging deer on
this road and you're thinking you know
just how many of these do you have in
you and you and a very a handful of men
and women out there could not and say
you know what that means I don't I don't
lack the energy
um or the interest I I just I just am
being realistic about do you keep doing
the same thing for you know my contract
would run through like 10 years of doing
it 10 years seems like a good time to
say all right is that the only thing you
do is is that what you do who knows who
knows but I look I I love that I get to
do this I still am interested in the
things that happen and the stories that
happen and the nights where you get to
cover the biggest events feel huge and
then the challenges on the nights when
it doesn't feel like that can you still
paint the corners can you still still
throw strikes right
uh where do you stand on uh Monday night
countdown is that part of the resume now
no I I it was reported that I was the
guy and other than me not having been
offered the job or accepting the job I
haven't been offered it was spot on
um God that was weird I mean you you
read things and you're like whoa whoa
people were congratulating me and things
of that and that you're like it's very
strange to be the person who you know
you you hear an athlete or somebody in
sports say well that's just not true and
you kind of always think sure it is well
this was a situation where I something
was reported about me which was not
accurate now I don't want to be coy and
act like it couldn't happen
um I I have look I have a great boss uh
the people there have been incredibly
supportive and you you have you know
what this is about right you have
conversations and you you is it is this
something that would work is this
something that benefits you and me and I
can do something that helps us that
helps me find a different a different
sort of daily workload weekly workload
and if it is and it makes sense then
great but
um if it doesn't for whatever reason
then you know there are plenty of great
men and women at our place that could
that could do as good or better than I
in that spot but for the for for the
moment
um you know I'm supposed to go back in
August and uh hunker down for year nine
and off we go all right well maybe I'll
uh put my hat in the ring then if you're
not taking it official I hope you I hope
you don't you're a Hall of Famer I don't
need that I thought you I thought you
announced I couldn't figure out if
you're announcing you're retiring you
got an extension what was that well it's
it's both it's an extension but it's my
last contract therefore it's a contract
extension announcement and a retirement
never the last contract there no it is
doing this yes it is yeah it is and how
do you know and and what makes you know
that
because I made the decision
you made it today what if what if you
what if the you know how time goes It
goes by too quickly and then all of a
sudden it's like the last month and
you're like oh crap I still enjoy this
wait are you taking the over it's it's
four and a half
I'll bet under just because I TR I take
you with your word okay and I I I'm not
trying to be a jerk here I'm just saying
that I I think you and I have both
probably experienced it in a way that
maybe sometimes is a little scary you go
crap I'm how do we get to this place in
in the road where you start realizing
you're running out of Runway
um but I I listen I take you at your
word you say You're Gonna Go I believe
I'm a journalist I'll miss you how
how uh how do we process Brian Harman
winning the Open Championship
give me flowers man it's not any more
complicated than that this he's
I get that he wasn't the favorite but
this is a top 25 basically ranked player
in the world who was a stud in college
who went on tour he's one of those guys
that if he wins you go huh he had his
week where he was great and he was great
I think what I think what what happens
is that Majors the theater of Majors we
wait for them right and each one is a
little bit different and each one has
its own Flair and flavor but what the
Common Thread is typically is there's
incredible tension in drama and he
eliminated that largely because that
round he played Friday was impossible I
mean he got to 10 under and then it was
like it's his unless he wobbles and any
glimmer he gave of wobbling people were
like oh here it is he's he's gonna it's
a it's on now and he would just kind of
I must imagine giggling thing no it's
it's really not because he constantly
had the answer so
I understand that it wasn't wildly
exciting because he played great I
understand he wasn't the person that was
the name you expected perhaps but it
just speaks to the depth of American
Golf it speaks to how hard it is to win
majors and it was his turn I mean you
follow these you love the game at Aaron
Hills a few years back when when Brooks
won
um you know he was right there in the
mix and wasn't his turn uh he wasn't
about to spit the bid after he played
those great first couple of rounds I'm
happy for him I know him I like him
you'd enjoy him he's a huge sports fan
and
um you know he was absolutely fantastic
so to me I I say what I said to start
give him his flowers acknowledged that
he was he had the week of his life
did the drama of golf or surrounding
golf did the play match the drama around
the sport
no only because you didn't you knew who
was going to win unless there was a
Calamity and I'm talking about the
totality the entire year like the drama
of everything that's happened
and and the and the and the play that we
saw did it match
that's interesting maybe not just
because the the drama is the headline
right I mean guys wake up on a Tuesday
or whatever it was and it's like live
PGA merger and people like wait what I
mean I'm talking about the big boys yeah
woke up to the same news we did and they
were all just and now now I mean that's
that was a hell of a headline I don't
know how much I don't know when or how
it happened so no it that that is the is
a headline that kind of obliterates
anything which seems ridiculous when you
started with you know John Rahm and
Brooks kepco winning the first two
majors of the year I mean that's you're
on a hell of a trajectory there no
disrespect to Wyndham Clark and Brian
Harmon winning they deserved it but
those names don't pack as big a punch
headline wise as the headlines that came
in the middle of all this no so I guess
I guess those headlines and the question
marks that surround those headlines are
still probably the biggest story that
that the sport has to answer we started
with your Orioles we'll end with your
commanders uh the over under for your
Commanders
six and a half
how do you feel as a commander did you
already win how many wins did you get
with Dan Snyder being kicked to the curb
at least 60 million it's it's well that
was that was that was a heck of a that
was a heck of a tariff on the way out
the door uh yes I mean and it's hard to
process unless you're in that region or
you really get what that what Washington
when they were the Redskins meant to the
NFC East
um it's
it was such a it was such a cloud that
followed and now it's it's lifted and
Josh Harris I think has done everything
right to start you just want to open the
doors and open your arms to those folks
and say we want you back we need you
back we're going to get back but we
can't without you you're invited and I
think the name Will Change just because
and I don't mean back to what it was I
just mean
this is the last sort of Vestige of the
Snyder era even though he didn't want it
I just think I think it'll be something
different probably next year
um I assume they'll try to go back to
the RFK spot if they can I don't know
the politics of it but I think you get a
new stadium you get a name that's new
you have a new owner and you say the
Washington franchise has a hell of a
history the last 25 years will sort of
act like it was a bad fever dream and
we'll lock arms and March into the uh
into the 2025s and Beyond where's the
puppy
I don't know he's wandering around
anything could be happening today at
this point he took a dump on another on
a podcast and no I could actually I've
got eyes on him and he's uh he's he's
actually he's he's almost a year now so
he's he's pretty trustworthy although
he's giving me that look with his ears
look like like oh am I you think so huh
uh thanks for joining us on your
vacation uh good to talk to you bud
always Dan be well that's Scott Van Pelt
the Mothership